bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy viajaremos a eeuu para
repasar 60 años de debates
presidenciales televisados el primero de
ellos ocurrió en 1960 entre dos grandes
figuras políticas del hemisferio
occidental john fitzgerald kennedy y
richard nixon
kennedy era senador y el candidato
demócrata mientras que nixon fungía como
el vicepresidente republicano de acuerdo
con la agencia de noticias británica
reuters
nixon rechazó el maquillaje con tan mala
suerte que las sombras en su rostro
impactaron a los 70 millones de
televidentes que vieron por primera vez
desde sus casas aquel debate en la
historia de eeuu de manera que pudo más
la imagen que el discurso la guerra fría
era uno de los temas candentes de aquel
debate presidencial tanto nixon como
kennedy defendían la integridad de
berlín occidental así como la
independencia de la isla de taiwán
antiguamente llamada formosa de un
eventual ataque de la china continental
de mao zhedong
los comunistas si nos dicen que su
objetivo no son las islas cercanas a la
costa y que solo son escalones para
tomarse formosa en el caso de que su
ataque fuera el preludio de una invasión
a formosa no hay duda de que eeuu
volvería a cumplir sus obligaciones como
en el caso de berlín y apoyaría a
nuestro aliado formosa
[Música]
el señor nixon sugiere que eeuu debe ir
a la guerra si estas dos islas son
atacadas yo sugiero que si se ataca a
formosa o a las islas pescadores o si
hay una acción militar en cualquier área
parecida que indique un ataque entonces
eeuu estará en pie de guerra para
defender su tratado tras varios debates
presidenciales entre nixon y kennedy en
octubre del año de 1960 y aunque uno de
ellos los separó a más de 4.800
kilómetros de distancia nixon en los
ángeles y kennedy en nueva york' fue
este último quien se quedó con la
presidencia ya en 1976 terminada la
costosa y dilatada guerra de vietnam
pero aún en tiempos de la guerra fría
tuvo lugar un segundo debate
presidencial televisado tras 16 años de
espera en esta oportunidad el demócrata
jimmy carter se enfrentó ayer al forn el
republicano que había reemplazado a
nixon tras el escándalo de watergate
pero la guerra fría no quedaba atrás en
la agenda y la posición sobre la unión
soviética pesaba mucho en el electorado
de manera que el periodista max frank
the new york times le hizo una pregunta
clave a gerald ford quien hasta ese
momento no sabía que le costaría la
presidencia
no hay dominación soviética en europa
del este y nunca la habrá bajo la
administración formal
entendí que dijera que los rusos no
están usando europa del este como su
propia esfera de influencia y no están
ocupando la mayoría de los países allí
ante la contrapregunta del moderador
gerald ford tuvo una nueva oportunidad
de replantear su respuesta y esto dijo
no creo que los rumanos se consideren
dominados por la unión soviética no creo
que los polacos se consideren dominados
por la unión soviética y eeuu no concede
que esos países estén bajo el dominio de
la unión soviética desafortunadamente y
como apunta mary miller en la biografía
de gerald ford los países de europa del
este que él mencionó si estaban bajo una
dominación del abuso momento clave del
debate que supo aprovechar su contendor
jimmy carter me gustaría ver al señor
ford convencer a los polacos
estadounidenses los checo
estadounidenses y los húngaros
estadounidenses de que esos países no
viven bajo la dominación de la unión
soviética suave y unión tajante ante el
error de fort y peor aún la reiteración
del mismo fueron su cruz en los medios
de comunicación el demócrata jimmy
carter resultaría electo presidente de
los eeuu en 1976 pero en 1980 cárter
perdería contra ronald reagan el
presidente que en 1984 se lanzó a una
exitosa reelección al sortear con humor
una pregunta sobre sus 70
años de edad
quiero que sepas que tampoco haré que la
edad sea un tema de esta campaña no voy
a explotar con fines políticos la
juventud y la inexperiencia de mi
oponente you también experience
de acuerdo con ericsson un antiguo
portavoz de la casa blanca los momentos
en que los candidatos reciben una
pregunta en tiempo real son decisivos
para su éxito o para su derrota como le
sucedió a mitt romney en el debate
presidencial de 2012 contra barack obama
cuando respondió con desatino a una
pregunta relacionada sobre la
desigualdad laboral entre hombres y
mujeres hicimos un esfuerzo concertado
para buscar mujeres que pudieran estar
calificadas para convertirse en miembros
de nuestro gabinete fui a varios centros
de mujeres y les dije pueden ayudarnos a
encontrar gente y metraje carpetas
llenas de mujeres la expresión de mitt
romney finders football women que
traduce folios o carpetas llenos de
mujeres es una forma en inglés
despectiva de referirse a las mujeres
hecho que lo desplomó en las redes
sociales y que claramente le dio una
ventaja a su contendor y futuro
presidente barack obama finalmente en
2016 el debate televisivo entre el
republicano donald trump y la demócrata
hillary clinton
trajo a 84 millones de televidentes
marcando un récord en la historia de los
debates lamentablemente se trató de un
intercambio de insultos en el que
prevalecieron las acusaciones sexuales
en contra de trump y los deslices de la
misma índole del esposo de clinton
dos orientaciones porque ahora en
tiempos de pandemia se enfrentan
trump y joe biden de sus respuestas y
comportamientos en los debates dependerá
la suerte que tengan en las elecciones
de noviembre así llegamos al final soy
andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir estas historias que las
encuentran en france 24 punto com
[Música]